hello everyone welcome to another
session by simply learn
today
we are going to discuss the base theorem
an important subtopic that comes under
probability theory
we'll start this video by talking about
probability and conditional probability
after that we'll move on to the bayes
theorem and understand its formula and a
real-life example where the base theorem
can be used
so
let's get started
what is probability
probability is a branch of mathematics
concerning numerical descriptions of how
likely an event is to occur or how
likely it is data proposition is true
the probability of an event is a number
between zero and one
where roughly speaking zero indicates
the impossibility of the event and one
indicates certainty
the higher the probability of an event
the more likely is that the event will
occur
let's look at an example
a simple example is the tossing of a
fair unbiased coin
since the coin is fair
the outcome that is heads and the tails
are both equally probable
the probability of heads equals the
probability of the tails and since no
other outcomes are possible the
probability of either heads or tails can
be said to be 1 by 2 which is also 50
percent
the probability of an event can be
calculated by number of ways it can
happen divided by the total number of
outcomes
now that we know about the probability
let's see if you can answer this
question what is the probability of
drawing a jack and a queen consecutively
from a deck of 52 cards without
replacement
added options
post your answers in the comment section
and let us know
now let's move on to conditional
probability
let a and b be the two events associated
with a random experiment
then the probability of a is occurrence
under the condition that b has already
occurred and probability of b is not
equal to zero is called the conditional
probability
it is denoted by p a slash b
thus we can say that b a slash b is
equal to p a intersection b divided by p
of b
where
p a slash b is the probability of
occurrence of a given that b has already
occurred and p b is the probability of
occurrence of b
to know more about conditional
probability you can check our previous
video which is specifically on
conditional probability
now let's move on to bayes theorem
the base theorem is a mathematical
formula for calculating conditional
probability in probability and
statistics
in other words it is used to figure out
how likely an event is associated
on its proximity to another
bayes law or bayes rule are the other
names of this theorem
the formula for the bayes theorem can be
written in a variety of ways
the most common version is
p a slash b is equal to p of b a into p
of a divided by p of b
where b a slash b is the conditional
probability of event a occurring given
that b is true and p a and b of b are
the probabilities of a and b occurring
independently of one another
let's solve a problem using the base
theorem to understand it better
there is a cricket match tomorrow and in
recent years it has rained only 5 days
each year
unfortunately the meteorologist has
predicted the rain for tomorrow
now when it rains the meteorologist
correctly forecasts rain 90 of the time
and when it doesn't rain he incorrectly
forecasts rain 10 of the time let's
calculate what is the probability that
it will rain on the match day
so
the two sample spaces here are the
events that it rains and it does not
rain
additionally a third event is also there
that meteorologist predicts the rain
so the notation for these events appear
below
event a1 is equal to it rains on the
match day event a2 that it does not rain
on the match day and event b is the
meteorologist predicting the rain now in
terms of probability we know the
following
probability of a 1 is 5 by 365 that it
rains 5 days in a year which will come
out to be 0.0136
pa2 is 360 by 365
that is no days for 360 days in an year
which will come out to be 0.986
p b slash a1 is 0.9
this signifies when it rains the
meteorologist predicts that a 90 percent
of the time
in a similar manner pb by a2 is 0.1
that it does not train the meteorologist
predicts the rain 10 percent of the time
combining all this we can calculate p a1
slash b that is the probability it will
rain on the given mesh day given a
forecast of rain by meteorologist the
answer can be determined using the base
theorem as shown below
so here's the formula of the base
theorem and putting all the values that
we have calculated in the previous slide
the probability that it will rain on the
match day given a forecast of the rain
by meteorologist will come out to be
0.111
which will be equal to 11.11
so there's an 11 percent chance that it
will rain on the match day given that
the meteorologist has predicted the rain
i hope this example is clear to you
with this we have come to an end of this
video on the base theorem i hope this
was helpful
if you have any questions then please
put them in the comment sections also if
you like the video then please subscribe
to the simplyland channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
thank you for watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here